lapierre façon dont vous avez largué
quelqu'un s'était jetée ya très
longtemps adolescents et à l'adolescence
j'avais très peu de succès avec les
filles sauf les allemandes paris souffre
les avancées et les sharks avec angela
merkel pendant d'autres autres entrepôts
casser du nudisme est donc j'étais dans
des camps franco-allemand de deux
adolescents et le verre le lavandin les
jours je suis avec une allemande et a
laissé le moment jamais tout le monde a
trouvé formidable
on devait sprint elle et j'ai compris
qu'elle ne savait pas au moment où elle
est venue vers moi n'a fait est là c'est
un peu compliqué que par politesse
juillet comme l'est celle à booster
j'assume et plus du tout est resté un
jour et je voulais pas lui faire de la
peine donc en fait je me suis caché
pendant un jour dans le coma jusqu'au
départ normes et est demandé partout il
est loué moi j'étais caché dans les
buissons
elle est l'étape la turquie au petit à
petit
[Applaudissements]